neither good evening everybody
I'll start by really reading the
emergency evacuation announcement should
we be required to evacuate we will dim
would you please lead to building by the
nearest available exit there is one fire
exit in this room if you need to
evacuate the room do so by the glass
floor to the external fire speed
staircase please help both handles in
case the stairs are wet or slippery if
anyone is unable to use the stairs but
they please allow others to exit the
room before they go to the foreign
assistance after number Five's received
declarations of interest include in any
written declaration apology for
restorative justice
so item number six is the Community
Safety Partnership receiving welcome
these are mostly assistant director of
community health services counselor Mike
web for a holiday for community and kept
captain corner cost of wit and watch
with community and policing team thank
you all for coming this evening
members will have a copy of the report
and then toss a little bit nice we have
a discussion about that I ask you to
start off and just run through it Orson
and so the episode three point really is
just to headline some examples or mouth
bespectacled is just so she can
demonstrate and the team's contributions
and I particularly wanted to focus on
the fact that this is the time when
Community Safety officers are doing some
strategic assessment work which is the
annual review of the 12-month program of
crime trends so they can set the
priorities for the next financial year
and that meeting was held last week and
I can give you the heads up that the
priorities are not going to change for
next year not that we can see at the
moment obviously is still partners still
have to have that one to do bank with
each other and it can be signed up at a
local strategic partnership but just to
remind that those priorities are
protecting one of the people ASP
violence against the person and also
just an update from the report we only
heard end of last week that the office
of these five crime commissioner
as we did this year which is twelve
thousand three hundred and twenty seven
so that only came late and also I just
wanted to take this opportunity to say
that our Community Safety Officer
vacancy is now filled by officer and
Department we're only starting again
last week and here at the moment is
focusing on building up relationships
with partners and he's also prioritizing
on the ongoing project work such as the
walk-on line but been the holder with
also in July the year six which is about
and in safety and crucial crew and
senior safety days one of the reasons
why were here because because his energy
started
so thank you everybody for allowing me
to come see you this evening I'd ask you
to bear with me I'm new to the role so
and I'm not an expert on triggers but
I'll take questions
Pressey of some of the bits of interest
so the first thing I thought we might
just touch on is the precept increase
and what that means to the Essex police
budget and the stopping of your area
overall for Essex Police the the
increase in the precept will create an
increase of 215 officers to the police
certain Essex Police 78 percent of that
will be allocated to local policing so
most of that is coming out and will be
visible policing a Processing's I will
say that we have four officers joining
us in ruptured ready castle points as of
the 1st of April on the community
policing team and I through an earlier
conversation I'm not sure if you're
aware that they're two different types
of policing teams that we have the
community policing team is the team that
will deal with the overarching problems
of the area looking at trends looking at
anti-social behavior and dealing with
perhaps what may be perceived as the
lower-level incidents where as a local
policing teens who are also from my
memory receiving for extra staff as of
the 1st of April they deal with our
response emergency incidence so if
there's a call for assistance a collapse
whatever it is if it needs an immediate
presence but local policing team will
attend and the community policing team
have the overarching what's happening
what other trends happening
so we're getting four new staff joining
us on the 1st of April for a Rochford
rainy Castle Quint and community
policing this will support the local
priorities outlined by Louisa and all of
the policing priorities we are focusing
in at the moment in the area on our
operational operation nimble which is us
out and about as much as we possibly can
be visibly engaging with the public
sorting out problems as much as we
possibly can we're also very aware of
the anti-social behavior problems in the
area I will say that just just in this
last couple of weeks a trend that I'd
identified was a number of vehicles
being stolen in particular mopeds we
have arrested one individual in relation
to that and since his arrest it appears
that that trend has gone down because I
noticed it was that was quite a few of
them going over a couple of weeks but
since we've arrested that individual
that has gone down so my team's looks at
the trends the other objectives that the
priorities that were four subsets endure
but the new officers will be looking at
of course will be vulnerability and
domestic abuse and breaking that cycle
of domestic abuse I know that we're
working in partnership to do some work
there serious violence going to move the
nice crime and safety I didn't know
whether there was anything else but we
needed to talk about about the increase
in staffing so I'll stop on that thank
you
yes I just like so one point about the
increasing staffing we in this area
we're experiencing large developments
which consequently leads to a large
ingress of additional persons into our
community how do you deal with that does
a team bit an increase on a number of
properties or number of people is that
taken into consideration when you're
around your staffing levels
so there is a calculus
that's not my area of expertise no we're
just generally so there is a calculation
that is done on a finished level about
how many offices will work in a
particular area and I believe that
that's done on a regular basis I
couldn't tell you how often that is done
by the force do that review of how many
office dozen people what are the needs
of that area and the calculation
includes how many people live in an area
so when we talk about new developments
new people moving in thank you thank you
thank you Karen and you say the new
officers coming in are they regulars yes
oh that's a very good point yes they're
not special or anything like that it was
I had a conversation before we came into
the meeting about specials and about
what why'd you make that point on three
years ago talking to Roger host when we
were both on the campaign trail and he
promised that we would see more officers
on the streets these four new officers
coming too just to community policing
possible on to the local police meeting
but what I would say about specials and
again I'm wearing much for any council
point the area that I look after I have
two new specials that will be coming to
the area who are dedicated to air to
parts of the area so there'll be two one
dedicated to an area on family and I
think there's another one dedicated to
an area of Holdridge and what they that
means however those areas have funded it
those specials joining us so what
they've funded is those specialists
spending at least 16 hours per month I
think it is amia that's rotten or
nodding dedicated in that area and then
he'll be pulled out
area because that area is finding them
so sis at Rockford Perry were funding
two specials but they haven't got any
well I think one was Popeye through his
training and Brazil and right so you
were aware of the scheme and you haven't
started the process of getting them to
assist you so Rochford I'm not sure
where we are with them I did have the
coordinator for this scheme come down
and speak with me the other week I'll
ask him for an update Thank You Jamie a
couple questions and first one I think -
Luisi you stated that the grant amount
of grant coming from an Essex Police for
this has remained the same as last year
correct me if I'm wrong but understand
from last year it was the same situation
where the amount bad that came through
was the same from the previous year that
correct so basically we've had two
consecutive years of no increase okay
hmm and the other question is it's a bit
more sort of tropical in relation to
nice crime which is obviously quite a
headline at the moment I understand it
that since 2010 to 2018 not a crime is
risen by 11 percent in London but by 45
percent in Essex over the same period
obviously the number of incidents is a
low level that the increase is quite
dramatic and this is a reflection of not
crime instances that are happening in
greater numbers in the Shires
as
- the city's nice crime seems to be
related to gangs and gangs which are
dealing in drugs so on the basis that
it's been a significant increase in
reported knife crime in Essex how do you
see that happening on the ground and is
there anything that you feel about new
trends and where there there's something
that you can do about the instances in
the gang related aspects of it
so my feeling about knife crime only
ones I have been here terribly wrong but
I'm not feeling knife crime is a problem
in your your district what would say is
this is knife crime week and I've come
away last week we are now to doing lots
of educational stuff we're out doing
this stuff we're doing we've got the
knife arch up we are I think importantly
trying to educate people around not
having knives but I would have to say
it's not a huge issue to us now that's
my perception I haven't looked at the
statistics and it is with regret I'm not
a statistician and I don't know the
figures from 2010 to 2018 so my
apologies I haven't read now just moving
on from some of your points there it's
really it really cuts across what I
wanted to talk about next anyway our up
falcon and the work that they do around
guns around knife crime about around all
of that sort of work so i don't know if
you want me to start talking about that
or if there are any other questions yeah
if you can if i can help on some council
hook questions or queries and then
a lot of people have indicated it's
another question I have some notes and
forgive me I'll be looking at my notes
as I talk about what the [ __ ] house
it seemed to make sure that I was fully
updated and what they've done are you
aware of what we call op fokin in your
district so we have a team of one
sergeant and four officers in plain
clothed officers who are out there
dealing with drugs organized crime and
county lines County lines does that mean
anything so that is their main focus now
you won't see them out there terribly
often unless you might have seen on
their Facebook that we have executed a
number of warrants in recent times and
that would account for some of her stats
that have arisen recently around drugs
it looks as if we had a sudden peak in
drugs but what I would suggest has
happened is we've been out doing
warrants around drugs and that's why
they've recorded it does a lot more for
the month of February but it is their
role to go out and get the intelligence
and that's something else I need you to
assist me with when you're talking with
the public about getting intelligence
into us your right knife crime does seem
to sit very very closely with the drugs
problem when when there's a knife
incident how I perceive it is what I'm
seeing is it's generally related to a
gang incident yeah so it's not it's not
generally happening out there is a
related instaweather now Erik Falcon
were introduced around this long time
last year and in the year that they've
been going one sergeant and four
officers they have arrested 85 people
they have executed 24 warrants they have
submitted intelligence reports 750
intelligence reports and it's as a
result the intelligence reports that
informs how we get our warrants and
thereby arrest 80 stop searches have
been put in and they have seized for
Tasers three machetes four knuckle
dusters two imitation firearms and ass
and one life one life yeah so I think
there's more gravity knife is dreadful
but a Taser a machete goodness me
they have so far seized drugs cannabis
341 grams and when we talk about grammar
print when we talk about the cannabis
again we need intelligence to come in
from the public more so about Class A
and Class B drugs of course we need
intelligence about all drugs what I
would say though is if you're submitting
intelligence about cannabis we will need
we need to we need to grow a picture of
what's happening and cannabis being
lower level it may be that that cannabis
is fueling the other drugs supply or use
but all I would say to you is one piece
of intelligence about cannabis doesn't
mean we're going to go into a warrant at
that address we need to have a picture
before to they've seized in excess of
five thousand pounds in cash not all of
that has come from the process has been
seized under the price
Crime Act which means it's bits put back
into place in the South stage I have
seized five stolen vehicles including
some mopeds
so the OP Falcon team are out there
they're doing some really good work
we're really pleased that they're also
tapping into the vulnerabilities so
we've got children young people who have
perhaps are connected who have child
sexual exploitation or child
exploitation flags against their name
they're doing work around those young
individuals in a community to ensure
that they're not dragged into I hope
that gives you a flavor of another team
that's part of the community policing
team but are out there trying to do some
work in this just that quickly obviously
your police Nerys can't console point
and runs for district in relation to
what you've been saying obviously our
focus is for rockford is there is the
incidence more related to one one eight
one eight area than another is it more
and castle point in here or is it fairly
even most definitely it's more in
council point than here but what I do
ensure is that steam we had at least two
of those warrants that were in the
Rockford area just in the last one in
February so we try to ensure that we are
looking at intelligence from across the
district and servicing both sides of the
district as much as we can when we talk
about county lines the Rockford area
doesn't have a great problem that we're
aware of in relation to county lines and
we have one so any information and you
can tell me that you can get in to us we
have one that's simmering and we need
more information to inform what we do
about that one particular County
okay thank you Jim Thank You counselor
mr. boy I'll save your mother I detected
earlier so it's going back on in two
weeks now we'll just have a quick
follow-up though it's just about the
police numbers the fall from the 1st of
April Virginia relating to the previous
increase in the precepts I think they'll
turn about a year or 18 months to train
up
is that correct God or are the four
additional officers in relation to the
precepts which is just going up my
apologies
[Music]
what numbers how many PCs are in the
area and how many PCSOs are in there is
that the first of a problem that's
Contra Costa point on the way about this
one I have a team of three sergeants I
[Music]
was referred to sorry I didn't refer to
be a properly community so how many
belonging that means replacing team yes
from the first rifle so I have three
sergeant yeah yeah there will be 14
constables and forgive me and seven pcs
those I believe the top of my head
because previously and there should have
been a warning from and the preceptor
coming in will be an increase on those
as well
in the future okay thank you just in
relation to the movie on because it
wasn't a question I'll indicate before
but as I'm here the residents have the
residents have problems reporting
information I always tell this report
when I won or online have they is trying
to convince them that it is doing any
good because they just had that's it as
far as they're concerned that's what
they hear I'm away you do post on
Facebook about your successes but and
it's just trying to convince residents
to report it and it will do some good
that's the only that's the only problem
I find
it's the same for me as a police officer
I'll put information and never know what
happens to it afterwards and I know
that's really difficult but I would i
can't urge you enough use the online to
it online facility put it in that
message box whatever the information
winter as promised it's not a crime
that's happening now there's no risk
behind it immediately use the online
system in terms of the police resources
yeah but he's poking it up through
population science friends I understand
it is really difficult when people don't
get those updates and I wish there was
some way to for us to get back to
everybody with all of the information
that comes in people do need to give the
information you need to be assured we
need that intelligence to do lots of the
work that we do Thank You chairman two
things come to mind money is with the
additional pays will they be working
during the day and not of an evening or
night how many will be doing that and
the other thing is we you did mention
whole bridges as one of the police in
from one of the teams or one of the
person that's daily bit there
could I ask you to also bring in Roth as
I'm a parish counselor there roy roy
fees is or has been really inundated
with burglaries and what have you and
and with as you very well or may not
know it is a farming community if you
like and it's very rural and and with
i've had several reports from
farmers of having quadbikes run across
their grounds and through their front
gardens if you like to get to those
grams so I would ask you if you could
put on your list okay coming in this
year we're coming out I haven't seen the
unindicted with burglaries in what time
are you talking about oh they were the
heirs of the Moline three of club two or
three colleges over what time period are
we talking about
Oh recently just in the last couple of
weakness yeah very much so in the last
couple of weeks
yeah very much so well one I had one
resident who loses his long amount of
yearly
which is not very pleased back because
your thousand pounds of time the other
thing if I may just add on to that Mike
German just just a quickie
just a quickie with with this in in in
moment or for placing you I mean you're
happy with with the sort of a router
that goes on sort of thing you have a
same pattern that will actually do that
the the thing that I'm trying to get at
is though I've had have had residents
that don't nine nine nine and have been
put through to 101 when the incident
occurs and they've got photographs and
everything like that and it's not until
a few days later that they actually get
a call back if they get a call back at
all and I'm referring to that guy that
loses he's gone though because he's
pretty annoyed about there
so nine nine nine well he wanted well he
seek the guy drive it away and he wanted
the police they're sort of ASAP I've
damage isn't always possible with talk
about specific I think it's probably if
everybody would for you to address but
you do go for each looked at it as 101
gives information but I want the police
there they're sort of think so 999 is
please think but how do you make yeah
everything gets prioritized I think the
point there would be when we're talking
about a 999 core it's about risk it's
about saving life II with me so it's
yeah and I said what everybody wants to
see there immediately either gone that
there with a baseball bat told him not
to actually cancer the people he
mentioned about the sparkage just for
clarity just remembers amenity where we
don't have any influence or say over
that budget or setting of that budget
doing there's nothing we can do to
increase it or the comp state the case I
mean every year obviously really
anything with the office anyway so
they're seeing a delivery plan there's
no reflection on time
so you know you can't leave all and just
communicate with them and update them
and still have activity looks like when
do you talk about setting the priorities
the priorities are the same as they were
last year I'm assuming that when in
determining what the priorities are that
is based on crime statistics so if their
priorities are standing safe does that
mean that the quants crime statistics
aren't producing what happens in
put-in-bay simplistic terms a strategic
assessment effectively looks like a
rolling program crime statistics over
the last 12 months and then effectively
ranks those are over particularly high
and against those you might set some
overarching priorities I mean there
haven't been any significant changes in
crime trends over the last year which is
why priorities are staying the same you
know there's still some significant
changes but our numbers are normally
very small so sometimes it does look
like a large proportionate change one of
those were measuring if it's the same
priorities year in year out if they
receive an attention and become an
authority I think that people who may
expect to see a slight reduction in
those areas as a way of it's determined
it's been successful the Germany is our
priorities are quite overarching so
protecting vulnerable people for example
we kept it particularly broad which
because
don't particularly want to just deal
with domestic abuse we want to deal with
domestic abuse we want to do with CSC so
there I mean prevention is always very
difficult isn't it to measure it is
difficult one and burglaries it's absent
doing is still pretty consistent an ASB
notice you spent is recorded on crime
trends as going down and always has but
we put it in there as a priority because
we recognize perceptions on a different
level compared the conference very much
and in there is easy to talk about an
interesting of Gangnam the action plan
and a workers deliver bar the community
sales partnership if they were happy
with the work that's being delivered and
that budget would have been come across
some time ago so I think we haven't seen
an increase I accept that but actually
we've maintained the level of the budget
which I think we've done that that's a
reflection of the excellent work at the
partnership in the last couple of years
okay thank you councillor kidding how
closely we might not notice our rum they
Community Safety Partnership working
with the youth strategy group I'm the
division yoga left preventative work
there and we obviously outreach going on
with this youth service generally so and
that's consistent sort of been funding
not only safety past year but
housing industry works that's probably
our biggest there's Nick O'Farrell
officers well it's something both groups
you've gone and actually synergy there
in terms of that working relationship
ticket from Essex County Youth Service
counselor mrs. wood yeah hi I just
wanted to say this special that's coming
to hope enjoyable and I don't want
people to think that parish council
asked for one and they got from the time
that they inquired about it to the time
and they've got it
it's probably been about 18 months do
you got me so I don't want people to
think over they've asked for one and
they've got one just like that but they
deal because you've got wait for people
to volunteer and have and I think that's
just important I just wanted to put I
just wanted to put that out it just so
happens that your special lives in your
area yeah interested yeah he's fully
trained he's got he's gonna have a
police dog he's you know he's got all
sorts of attributes that will be really
useful to ya and now the training of
course takes about my business so if he
if he hadn't have been a trained officer
yeah chairman um just going onto the
funding again five I know there's
nothing you can do about it but does the
office of the police in fact be sure and
I still help their Innovation Fund it
was some publicity for now he was about
two hundred thousand usually that you
could be two four yes they do have fun
this available to meet you
just a bit for and that's a couple of
bits have been submitted their
organizations are working yes because we
don't get directly involved we just
endorse those pieces that come through
and just make sure that those the links
really but again you couldn't encourage
those want to trigger groups to deliver
things that match your phone it's not
without monies public yeah and counsel
appeared in mention about the edge
strategy and for their bodies he's still
got a small pot of funding so there's
another option there you must uh some to
get intelligence across and now that'll
be great I think if the police can put
that message out and the best way for it
to be reported to them and perhaps also
what you're looking for we can then I
think I urge people to do that and I've
used the word intelligence but I
actually mean information yeah so it
doesn't really matter what it is if we
make it into intelligence by the
processes that we put it through or
everything and there's groups out there
we've got a little smaller local dog
watch that sort
and j9 I know what is I wonder sometimes
if a lot of our residents do I see it
still going to be promoted in the action
plan house it can this be sort of
expanded at all and I think that I mean
if we're teaching the business is about
j9 and educate and then can we educate
them around anything such as
intelligence I would just think if you
had another presentation at one of the
business breakfasts or something around
some of the things that businesses could
get involved in apart from just this for
Louise are really um you science is
based going down is that because it's
not actually being reported at least
it's not the reason we are you sign up
Biggers going down everybody is that
because we're not getting our residents
to import that they're thinking it's not
worth reports in the crime I don't know
this is all just a series like throw
away in question I mean that velocity I
had a problem
your week and I wrong on what I want and
they put me straight through to know I
know I know I always still
I don't I run up and I got straight
through which was really good I'm just
wondering how we actually been saying
how we can get residents actually
reports on it because if I know in one
part some on board
I'm social behaviors really bad but of
course if they're not reported in you're
gonna say there's nothing wrong with it
you know what the answer is to you
I could pass it straight back down so
what were you doing about until we
really get our is about categorizing as
well so someone might come in with an
incident which they make decision to be
a actually I think it's encouraging just
post it here please report because
actually posting on a Facebook does not
count that's what I think just the same
please do it but it wasn't just in a
message on a Facebook group I don't
think we're good at that don't you thank
you very much counselor mrs. Matsen
thank you questions for you and you've
given us a whole list of achievements
when this great yeah quiring property
and I think it was 85 and race how many
of those arrests were actually put up
with charges and convictions have you
done that we haven't got those details
because would say is that the team
reminded me that when we're talking
about a number of different
such as drugs the evidence gathering
process takes that long actually for an
awful lot of the drugs drops we still
haven't gotten pretty court because
we're not still gathering getting the
the evidence from expert witnesses so
there's so much to do it does take some
time so they remind me before I walked
out this evening with her when we talked
about the clocks
it's not just drugs it is some race yeah
but not all of them get dealt with by my
team so we'll go out and affect the
arrests we know something all for this
happened we'll go out and play to the
arrest and then we pass it on to another
team to continue that investigation
because it's such a small team we can't
do all of the does that make sense
well it makes sense yes but it doesn't
actually give a clarity that discerns of
the situation there the other point I
imagine I think it's been raised by a
couple of other members and it's one I
think that needs to be addressed
is what intelligence or information but
there are as has been mentioned lots of
people not reporting crimes and
certainly I know in our area there that
the overriding when it's a low-level
crime of theft particularly and possibly
antisocial behavior although I've got no
personal evidence of that or knowledge
of that that's anything that the
perception is there is absolutely no
point in reporting it that means that
your statistics are understated
naturally if they're not reporting
something that goes wrong then they
hardly likely to tell you give you
information either if they see something
that may or may not be of interest so
somewhere and somehow I think you need
to look at the levels of communication
you need to look at the way of perhaps
giving feedback and I realize you can't
do it in every situation where you could
give some general feedback because at
the moment those lines of communication
aren't there and from what I've been
observing with residents in the public
forums like Magnum cap it's actually
getting worse that the impression is
there is no
in reporting it and even when you say
placed of my Center at residence please
report it because you'll get current
reference number and with that for our
effort these are actual crimes with that
client reference number if there's a
patch of them it will indicate a problem
they still don't see any point in
reporting it so that that is something
that a communication that needs to be
addressed
and it needs to be addressed seriously
counselor start session coming on that
it's a really good point they picked up
a pair of examples and your community
team now your community 16 and a while
back they were gathering feedback from
some of the guys in the community you
ladies will now have bad back around the
guys at the round and the motives one of
those mopeds then got taken away from
they fit that back to me and I said
that's great because we've got these
situations coming we could actually
that's it could you just then published
with a picture of that but I've been
taken away which they did do and they
said thank you for the local do to local
residents and that we've been able to
take this uninsured vehicle the range
that would be an example yeah and also
when the embassies and when there is a
crime the importance of reporting it
because I can I certainly know some that
haven't and I'm not doing it because
that what they won't they been reported
to mean they don't want to report them
because they feel that it would be a
waste of their time and that's certainly
an attitude that needs to be addressed
and that is in you know generally over
the area hot clean brush with at that
particular area and it's probably more
widespread I would guess
yeah nice um we discussed within my
series obviously number they may be
being directive but it's not reach it's
not reaching and it's not this
conversation about how do we get out to
the community and to talk to them
effectively and I say what what means
can we use barely might have a reduced
number in team so we've used social
media and I've talked about the media
generally ideas what Facebook is only
used generally by eleven equal so we did
coffee we know I think however that
medium that information comes to you by
whatever means there you need to go back
generally on the same mace if someone
reports it five nice book yes go back to
my facebook but you've got Twitter you
guys that the youngsters don't use
Facebook and I suspect that they less
the smaller more antisocial behaviors
done by youngsters more than the older
people so they are the ones you're
trying to this section there's no point
in winning on Facebook what my children
certainly would really children whether
they said it would look at Facebook it's
not it's not used we try to Instagram
Twitter it's not I think maybe we should
just if everyone
[Music]
I think you can expect us to give you
anything else that's what I think you
all today to take there is a problem
communication and lucrative perhaps
discuss it and I'm reassuring to I have
discussed it with my team we're trying
desperately hard to understand how we
get that communication right so that's
what I'm coming to the community and
saying it helped me to make that
communication right for everybody is
difficult and it will be really
difficult to do I'm not trying to pass
you the problem I'm asking for help they
need any feedback and the feedback needs
to be as councilman purchase I think if
you've saved these motorbikes you you
can say you have this is an example of
what the information has done and put it
out and put the positive out there
rather than the negative just quickly
we've been talking some intelligence
gathering and passing on to yourselves
there are mean go around the table you
can all tell you where the allocated
drug-dealing goes on in a particular
district and I appreciate the resources
beginning you don't I'm sorry I we could
find you most at the arc and Sunday
afternoons or whatever it's like this
drug dating going on
yep basically a lot of marijuana but
there is coke there is other stuff going
on now it's pretty common knowledge
semion buckle give you a listing
particularly riley one or two places i'm
sure but other than nothing I'll just
see if I can change oh geez my field
yes skatepark teen shelter and they are
we're getting concerned that Nick ident
ought to play area that because they're
but you're talking about having these
plainclothes guys here and and great no
problem but sorry it wouldn't have to
see them every dumb Saturday afternoons
see what was going on and I know
we have reported in our youth workers
have reported it I just as a local
counselor feel that perhaps to actually
have a little group of your guys sitting
in there one after I'd say you haven't
got to sit there for long right true
true it's all going on there and John
will tell you where it is in in his area
and I'll bridge and I think this is is
the frustration that we feel we've
reported time and time again is nothing
new we get frustrated though what can we
do I say we employing youth workers
they're doing what they can from Essex
County Council and now we're working
with a mega center as well they're doing
what they can with the kids but actually
we need somebody to go in there and make
a few arrests sighing and that's why
ever a bigger in pain and at times what
we're trying to do my team are actively
working on stuff they've got their
priorities and we're trying desperately
hard to keep up with what priorities
aren't doing the work that we can I know
it sounds ridiculous I do hear you I do
hear you but if you make a nuisance of
yourself and forgive me that's really
the wrong word but forgive me for you
know I hope you don't mind in this
context if you make a nuisance of
yourselves to us then we will have to do
something about I have to be with me and
that sounds ridiculous but what's
happened is is that somebody else
somewhere else has found us ten times in
the last ten minutes and said didn't see
you with me and so team we've got to
stop this and so you're you've done it
just once this week look this one's got
ten twenty calls on it so that's what
we're all off doing that does that make
sense so I say to people I'm so sorry
but please could you make a nuisance of
you okay
[Music]
so it kind of starts counselors are just
coming on that June actually confer or
with your self in colleagues we do
because there's a major major place
where they do the drugs uh we've done
with the homeless and they get the drugs
from this place and they bring them in
on the train surrounding right and we've
told I've told both sets place and it's
still happening and the guys guys
actually tell me you know when they're
going because they all go down they're
all big drag when they come up as high
sky so you're not letting me know
exactly where they're going and up
towering and we know where they go next
I've moved it you know there's moved it
yeah well there used to be behind the
toilets what they're not down this is
yourself ain't right and now where they
get all their drugs is in South Church
the toilets in there so under they all
grabbed her in there they've got a
dealer in there haengju them out and
they push them out so when they cost
we've got a straight line they come down
from The Wall Street or London drop the
drugs off the dish them out I mean I can
go back in the key Crockett and you want
people bicycle rightly rock to dinner to
pick the drugs up and that's happening
all day every day yeah because once
you're not an addict
you need them every day yeah you know so
that is happening anytime and I've had
discussions with the place in Southend
and I have reported it it's a coffee and
cops I don't know if anything's happens
with it I'm just wondering if you do
confer thank you Robles name just
firstly on communication I think
communication cannot be as good as it
used to be because you're lacking the
community resources and I think from
experience in college when we had them
they they were a good conduit for
information I expect people and they
were respected and these are the earthy
spoke to them and I think I fortunately
whatever we you try to do that cannot be
as good as people on the street nothing
else Metropolitan Police clue to the
officer of the year last year nothing
Hines will you before that's that
comment but it doesn't help anything I
think money easy answer coming back to
them the priorities one of the ones I
operate this counselor and mrs. Vinson
is raised is the j9 issue of course
we've been trying to push this for a few
years there some offshore called direct
witness to probably do he's room
counselor web we've been pushing it for
a few years after it was a bit more
abundant for a few years and people I
think probably another third year would
be never using it what response do we
get from j9 is it effective or not
there's no B three three years we've
been pushing it quite hard with digital
training I don't I just there's no
feedback in the on the inflation figure
thing and that's another thing I think
the feedback we've had for this strategy
this year isn't as good as the previous
year where we had caught 1/4 2/4 3/4 for
responses we haven't had anything on
this one and just an additional one to
that with domestic abuse
I didn't notice in the 1718 outcomes
that of the referrals for domestic abuse
I understand absolutely five always
drawn which was a little bit worried
modernisation on that but that was a
question
so whatever reason that may have been
wrong so that is about making people
safe in their own home so just on j9 it
does continue to be a success story for
example this time this year so far over
ten new locations I agree outcomes at
the moment you're not seeing quarter one
quarter two quarter three we've decided
we've kept the delivery plan as a
genuine Brooklyn on her website and
we're working plans at the moment to do
an overarching codify this is what we've
done so I apologize it hasn't been as
good as it has been previous years which
is doing one people on Twitter for but
Jane I just came back to j9 for us it is
a continuing success story that's the
same we had over ten so you are we sorry
the Chairman on if we're measuring the
success of Jane Eyre but the number of
businesses or you that's about that's
good but I'm trying to I don't try to
get fit of how many referrals have been
made through Joe nine I'm at a point yet
am i doing as a measure of success but
also with a number of people goes
just a refresher around awareness at a
very low level nothing so going to thing
I can't measure that of course I think I
won't need for outcomes it's one of
things on my last one crucial crew in
terms of it's a fantastic event the kids
love it but actually what what the
belongings have benefits of that
together and visual food
last year in backing actually going to
touch the scores know three or four
weeks after essentially what can you
remember hmm how is is actually
benefited you have you changed your
behavior as a result of M on this but we
found at the mega sensor and response is
really positive actually that means
better than participating in terms of
had led to behavior change among so she
is six cocles but that's about looking
at the outcomes as well as outfits
because I'm not being I greatly weakened
needs evidence and members bhisma can
take poor but we can get smart about
those council be fierce and wanted to
come in on this point and then I've got
one more question I think um Thank You
chairman XJ notice how its target is I
know quite a few hairdressers target you
only need to see the story that was in
the papers long ago and it's just
stopped in that one domestic homicide
which would cost the council a chance
encounter one last question short
question from counseling thank you Jim
[Laughter]
the question is when is a crime a crime
for drug taking what have you because it
seems prevalent at them at the moment
that there's helium or laughing gas
which is very prevalent at the moment
and it's causing disruption to the
elderly in the district and it's
obviously happening on their front lawns
and what a view of what the youngsters
are doing on the back of counselors
standing when when is a crime not a
crime I mean in relationship to drugs
and stuff is this the issue of personal
use and also actually involved in
selling and you know being a being a
dealer so you know and how do you look
at this this this issue between the gray
area between personal use and dealing
you know is that come up as an aspect
when investigations are looking at you
know whether that's taken in further if
you know on issues of do we if they stop
and search taking place in in in the
area area and and do people get picked
up with you know smaller items but does
that connect to are they actually just
using that for their own personal or is
it part of a wider thing right okay so
when we look at the cannabis cannabis
politically cannabis was downgraded in
quite recent years wasn't it so are we
talking about small amounts of cannabis
that will be given a lower level
disposal by the officers it might be a
ticket it might be a warning you with me
so cannabis personal use small amounts
you will have to forgive me I don't know
it I can't remember our measurements so
I'll clearly get it out when I need it
for the particular job that we're
dealing with but they'll be they'll be
amounts that will fit for personal use
and there will be amounts that will fit
for dealing any other drug any other
drug will be dealt with
wouldn't it be drill don't require the
low-level disposals so any other drug I
mean cocaine heroin they're all hard
drugs bearing in mind that what if we
arrest somebody for a drugs offense then
we'll be doing a house search to find it
so its bigger than just how much they've
got on them it there'll be Intel led
investigations into what's going on I'm
so sorry I feel as if I'm floundering
Hollis's it's it's not my area of
expertise it is my team's area of
expertise and if I'm honest I've
forgotten the question
you want to repeat in try again but it's
not my area of expertise in relation to
drugs under the law thank you very much
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
April the executive meeting 1618 was the
voluntary sector grant allocation 20 19
and 20 and the meeting is next week I
looked it up and as a sort of rumours
booked out for it yeah well it was
originally for February
yep after the meeting is usually set up
then we've got 119 well hands financial
assistance policy I think we'll be
seeing the report coming out the end of
this week what I understand
and again that was supposedly a February
1 environmental health service plan 219
estimates of money that's been on there
and that's the regular one we see and
then find me the onion new one 319
obviously basically they're just trying
to change the standard 21 by invoice
paying the time to 30 days to Comanche
that's people paying us within an extra
time to plan that's what we're trying to
do we trying to go to business and I
think human why they tell me most people
did what stick to basically standard and
ignore anything like that
let's raise more money
not really much too much to say cause
becomes in the end of the year next
month we will add the annual report in
between that time we also have a meeting
of the project groups for the review of
the Constitution and the ICT